[Music]
in 2011 I had the opportunity to visit
the Polish National Film School in which
at the invitation of the great director
Andre Biden I was a trip I'd wanted to
make for years as I had long long been
drawn to polish cinema from the time I
was a film student my you I learned not
just how films are made but why school
nurtured in me and unshakable belief in
artistic expression grounded in Italian
Neorealism French new-wave
in polish cinema
[Music]
[Applause]
a great sweeping humanistic intimate and
profound films that were an integral
part of what looking back seems more and
more like the Golden Age of
international cinema that's why it's
such a great honor and a thrill to be
able to bring to us audiences
masterpieces of Polish cinema it's a
series of 21 films by directors such as
Andre beta
Christoph Sanusi Andre Mook their James
Cavallaro rich Wojcik rjs Alexander for
Christophe as lousy and others this is a
cinema a personal vision a very strong
social commitment and a poetic
responsibility from which we've all
learned and which sets a very very high
standard that as a filmmaker I strive to
achieve with every film every time now
each of these films in this special
series embodies what bita called the
impertinent freedom of creativity in the
cinema these are films that have great
emotional and visual power they're
serious films that with their depth
stand up to repeated viewings the themes
in these films will resonate as they did
profoundly for me when I first saw ashes
in diamonds zone 59 or 60 I was so taken
by the film masterful direction the
striking visual energy and the shocking
performance by the big lab Chbosky
at that time in America they were saying
the Polish James Dean such an
electrifying performance there are many
revelations in the masterpieces of
polish cinema series and whether you're
familiar with some of these films or not
it's really an incredible opportunity to
discover for yourself the great power of
Polish cinema on the big screen in
brilliantly restored digital masters so
I hope you'll enjoy these great films as
much as I do
special thanks goes to the film
foundation and milestone films in the US
and di factory propaganda foundation and
Kino rpm Poland for making this
magnificent series possible
[Music]
you